how's tyrell trace our descent to garth
greenham
the legendary first king of the reach
who made the land bloom
but so too does every noble house around
us
it seems dear ancestor garth
planted as many flowers as he plucked
a king should have more consideration
for his line don't you think
for over a thousand years the green hand
sons and grandsons ruled the reach as
house gardener the offshoots of his
daughters grew into vast and powerful
houses in their own right except for
house tyrell
we chose instead to serve our gardener
cousins faithfully as stewards
to manage their stronghold of highgarden
and the daily affairs of the reach
our words are growing strong
and under our stewardship the reach did
just that
as did we
until a blundering king almost cost us
everything aegon targaryen had landed in
westeros king mirn allied us with the
rock to repel the upstarts army
one can only marvel that king mirn did
not reconsider when he saw the living
dragons against him
perhaps he should have sought counsel
from his trusted stewards before he set
out
then again
perhaps he did
at the field of fire aegon
and let us not forget his sisters
burnt the combined armies of the reach
and rock king mirn paid for his
misjudgment with his life and that of
his ancient family
in a day the reach had lost its king
its ruling house and most of its army
thankfully for everyone
my ancestor harlan terrell had better
sense
until the maesters sorted out the intel
among man's cousins
harlan the steward was acting lord of
highgarden
to ensure peace and life in the reach he
would yield the castle to aegon
the other castles and families would
then follow
as they had since the dawn age
aegon had a continent to conquer
and the fertile reach was too valuable
to raise he accepted harlan's proposal
and welcomed our lands into his kingdom
to show his gratitude aegon entitled
harlan to highgarden
the castle his family had served for a
thousand years
and made house tyrell his wardens of the
south choosing us over older greater
families in the reach
our house thus owed everything to the
targaryens
so is it any wonder we stay true to king
aerys even during his madness
and even after robert baratheon rebelled
some may question my father for laying
siege to the baratheon's home instead of
marching to aid prince rhaegar before
robert could kill him and scatter the
royal army
but let us not forget that we had
already dealt robert his only defeat of
the war at ashford if lord tywin
lannister had not
vanquished the mad king so suddenly
our siege would have destroyed robert's
home and his brothers and won the war
for ares
but when the targaryens fell
house tyrell again chose peace and
prosperity over war and devastation and
bent the knee to king robert baratheon
first of his name
the andals swept across westeros
destroying many ancient families and
kingdoms
when the invaders arrived at the reach
led by sir alistair tyrell
house gardner chose accommodation over
battle
hoping honors and marriages would save
the foreigners ambitions
the tyrells were welcomed into service
as hereditary stewards of highgarden
thousands of years later they repaid the
gardeners for their acceptance
when aegon targaryen declared that
westeros was now his
king murdered the ninth allied with king
lauren lannister of the westerlands
together they fought to save westeros
from another foreign barbarian
whose family practices put decent men to
shame
but the dragons won
and the field of fire claimed mern and
all his sons grandsons and brothers
instead of using the castle for what it
was built to do
harlan tyrell
surrendered it to aegon without a fight
in exchange
harlan was given the castle his family
had served for thousands of years with
all its attendant lands and lords
including my family
some great houses call us upstarts
but the truth is that while the starks
and lannisters fell to the targaryens in
defeat
house tyrell
rose
for thousands of years our family served
as loyal stewards to the kings of the
reach
until the last of their line unwisely
burned to death
resisting the targaryen invaders
to save the reach from a similar fate
we yielded the castle of highgarden to
aegon and his sisters
in gratitude
the targaryens gave house tyrell
dominion over the reach
and we became lords of the castle in
which for generations we had served
under the targaryen dynasty westeros
prospered
gone were the petty wars of seven
kingdoms and the endless thirst for
minor glories that drove them the
westerlands enriched the realm
the north guarded it
and the reach and riverlands fed it
this harmony is what robert baratheon
shattered with his rebellion against
ares targaryen
when the call to arms came though we did
not want to answer
the reach is a gentle land and honestly
the mad king was not much loved
but we owed peace and status to his
family
my father mace tyrell
called his banners and marched north to
battle the rogue storm lord robert who
had already defeated three forces in a
single day
and
at ashford
my father won
some chastened my father for not
pursuing robert after the battle
we had cut him off from the stormlands
the seat of his power
and he had fled north with an easy grasp
of lord tywin lannister the hand of ares
for 20 years
my father moved instead to lay siege to
robert's ancestral stronghold of storm's
end the rose would strangle the stag as
the lion pounced
so we waited
but the lion slumbered and roberts
slipped past the king's forces to join
ned stark
we could have lifted the siege and
deployed our armies north to aid the
crown
we could have stormed the walls of the
castle and made robert homeless
but we had ample supplies
control of land and sea
and most of all
patience
our siege would succeed
eventually
at little cost of life to us
if robert prolonged the war with minor
victories
our capture of storm's end would hasten
his downfall
and if robert won the war
well
it would not do for him to find us in
his halls with the bodies of his brother
stannis and his sworn men
when the lion finally showed his colours
and
purged king's landing
we knew our cause was lost
my father chose the peaceful route and
bent the knee to robert who heartily
pardoned us
strange
considering how we'd beaten him and
starved his brother to the brink of
death
we were to keep our lands castle and
title
but we knew that we would never be
welcome at court
it didn't matter
the reach was still the most fertile of
the seven kingdoms and under our hand
every flower even the rose needs pruning
then it grows strong
the reach is aptly named we're the ones
who give your hands something to do at
the table
as the most fertile region of the seven
kingdoms we grow the lion's share of the
grains and fruit that feed this country
especially now since the
rebels have burned down the other fields
yet as with all gardens weeds grow in
the reach too though few name them as
such
singers fill our heads with chivalry and
courtly love
fluff to make boys fight and girls swoon
oh the songs are good enough for a
pleasure barge down the manda they give
pleasure to the common people and
harmony to the realm
but if the rise of house tyrell proves
anything it's that virtue and honor have
their place and if you're not careful
that place is the grave
unlike the lannisters starks and aarons
we were never kings in our own right
house gardner ruled the reach since the
dawn age and we were their stewards
while they ward to enrich their already
rich domain we managed their castle of
highgarden but then aegon targaryen
landed with his dragons
nobody knows why the gardener king took
the field against him anyone could see
that a man who grows flowers should
beware a man who grows fire-breathing
monsters
but maybe it wasn't wholly his idea
maybe someone whispered in his ear about
all the face he'd lose with the other
six kings if he stayed home the rest is
history the last gardener king lost his
face along with his body and his steward
harlan terrell promptly yielded
highgarden to aegon my grandmother
swears that harlan was like most of our
men and grew up banging steel together
too loudly for a thought to penetrate
but luckily his wife had better sense
whatever the case in return for harlan's
show of sense aegon proclaimed house
tyrell the lords of the reach and
wardens of the south passing over all
the other houses with better claims
yet aegon chose
us
centuries later when his descendant
aerys faced rebellion the reach stayed
loyal
mostly
my father mace dealt robert his only
defeat in the war even if it was my
father's vanguard who did most of the
fighting before he arrived
after the battle of ashford we laid
siege to storm's end robert's home
unfortunately the war ended before we
could take it and free up our armies to
go save the king